i've just been watching um the parade go
past it's finished now all the people
are going back vladimir putin left from
the peter and paul fortress over there
and went up to the center of his
hometown as you say gave a speech didn't
actually mention ukraine directly but
talked about how the navy would soon be
be in possession of the zircon
hypersonic missile which russia has been
developing for quite some time and he
talked about how there was no class of
missile quite like it it can go nine
times the speed of sound and is uh soon
to be in deployment um with the russian
naval forces to be used he said as
russia sees fit to protect its
sovereignty and freedom and i've just
been talking to quite a lot of people
here in what is a very patriotic crowd
all about the notion that what russia is
doing now is protecting its sovereignty
and freedom against a hostile west
essentially uh america and the uk um
getting it in the neck from a lot of the
people here
who don't uh see ukraine as their enemy
at all they say it's you who are
creating this rift between brother
nations it is a moment uh on navy day to
think about the contribution of russia's
navy to the uh situation in ukraine when
you look at the fact that the black sea
fleet uh against a ukrainian navy that
it doesn't really have much capabilities
they've been blocked in their ports
their warships um are not not
operational um and yet the ukrainians
did manage to take down russia's
flagship warship the moskva uh and
another number of its other patrol boats
but what the black sea fleet has been
very effective in doing of course is
blockading ukraine economically stopping
the grain from leaving
five ukrainian ports but particularly
odessa and despite the fact that that
deal was struck in istanbul a little
over a week ago we still have yet to see
a single boat leave those ports laden
with grain because i think of the risk
of underwriting any of those ships as
they go through the black sea which is
heavily mined and the risk given the
fact that russia bombed the port of
odessa the very next day after that deal
was done
that they are not necessarily acting in
good faith